[Musique]
bye bye 75 tout va très bien une année
charnière pour le droit des femmes qui
inspire les humoristes dans la revue de
fin d'année
avoir une grosse main qui vient toujours
les ficelles
après cette année internationale de la
femme en 1975 qui se voulait une grande
réflexion sur la discrimination
l'Organisation des Nations Unies décrète
que chaque année le 8 mars sera la
journée internationale des femmes
les femmes demandent d'avoir accès à la
contraception et au droit de décider
pour elle-même
[Applaudissements]
mais le militantisme féminin date de
bien avant au tournant des années 1900
les femmes à travers le monde revendique
le droit de voter ce qu'elles obtiennent
au Canada en 1918 aux élections
fédérales
puis le travail des femmes est devenu
essentiel à l'effort de guerre et est-ce
une coïncidence c'est en 1944 que les
Québécois obtiennent enfin le droit de
voter aux élections provinciales mais il
faudra attendre près de 20 ans avant
qu'une première femme soit élue députée
à l'Assemblée nationale elle deviendront
des citoyens de première classe claire
que clean casse grain fait changer la
loi pour que les femmes mariées
obtiennent la capacité juridique pour
ouvrir un compte bancaire ou signer un
bail plus tard elle se souvient encore
de ce qu'elle a dû faire pour
s'installer à Québec dans les années 60
louer un petit appartement il fallait
que mon mari
signe contre signe je sais pas si les
gens sont au courant mais seulement 2%
des femmes qui occupent des positions
cardes la bataille pour l'équité
salariale et long
job que lui puisse payer ça a l'air qui
a encore l'amélioration de ce côté-là à
faire à travailler égal à la régal alors
en 1295 des centaines de femmes décident
de marcher de Montréal à Québec pendant
10 jours
du travail on est dans un monde très
très individualiste puis les femmes sont
isolées des demandes qui concernent
l'emploi le salaire minimum l'équité
salariale le logement social etc
[Musique]
élèves à la fin cette marche du pain et
des roses rassemble plus de 12000 femmes
sur la colline parlementaire c'est une
lutte qui ne prend pas fin demain ou
après-demain ça va continuer la
pionnière du féminisme au Québec
laissant entendre que la Journée
internationale des femmes aura encore
longtemps sa raison d'être et encore
aujourd'hui malgré les changements
législatifs des dernières années on a
énormément de chemin à faire dans le
réseau de la santé pour nos
professionnels surtout dans le domaine
privé dans les domaines non syndiqués on
voit que des écarts salariaux encore
important et qui ne se justifie d'aucune
façon que autrement que par la
discrimination
[Musique]
-Canada Montréal